[Music]
evocative questions focus on the process
of how you're experiencing not the
content so i would say to you tim what
happens to you
when you sit and do interviews with
crazy people like dr sue johnson
and she she tells you stories that have
you move into your own softer feelings
what is that like for you tim and you
might say oh i don't know i say well
what happens in your body tim can you
tell me a moment when you felt that rush
of emotion you say oh well it was when
you said this oh
so that's the trigger
and i'll help you put your emotions
together with evocative questions and
reflections and i'll say so when you
heard me say this that was important for
you that stood out and you started to
feel a lot of feelings can you help me
what happened in your body say oh well i
felt this tightness across my chest
and i felt like i wanted to cry
and then what did you say to yourself
i said to myself my goodness
that's just how i felt when i remember
feeling that way when i was three years
old
and i say i understand
so i'll reflect it again i'll hold it
for you i'll specify it i'll ask
evocative questions i'll get you to stay
with the experience and then i'll say
what do you want to do when you feel
that way and you might say
i want to stop it i want to get out i
don't want to feel any more of that
right now i want to shut it down
i want to stop the feeling say okay so
you want to run yeah and we've put your
emotion together in a safe specific safe
way
people can deal
with emotions that when they make sense
when they're acceptable to when there's
another human being they're accepting
them and when they're made specific
we can't deal with big vague huge
overwhelming
problems we just want to run away from
them so i'll use evocative questions
i'll use reflections
i'll use repetition
to help you stay with that feeling i'll
use an image
you know if you said to me
there's fire across i can remember one
client who said
it's like walking into a fire
when you ask me to turn and open up to
him i can tell you that i'm afraid i can
look into your face and tell you because
you're just a silly therapist you don't
matter to me much
actually that's what i said i said
that's because i'm just a silly
therapist and i don't matter too much
and she said yes that's right so i said
so i can tell you i can tell you about
my fear but when you ask me to turn
and tell him about my fear
you're asking me to walk into a fire
and i knew that this lady
she was a trucker
there was an accident in front of her
truck and she got out of her truck
and she walked into flames to pull out
the trucker who was trapped underneath
the truck in front of her i realized
that this is an enormously powerful
image
and
if i want her to move more into it if
she can handle it if she can't handle it
i'll stop
but if i want her to move more into it
and i think she can handle it i'll say
let's stay with that image
it's like fire fire burns fire is
terrifying
you're telling your partner
it's too hard for me i can't i can't do
this right now it's too hard it's like
walking through fire
to turn and open up to you i just can't
do it and she says yes that's right i
say good tell him that
now create
i'll
clarify the emotional music
help her with it help her accept it
and and you know and then i'll i'll help
her move this into a into into a drama
um with another person and by the way
when we do individual therapy we've just
started to really teach efit which is
emotionally focused individual therapy
there's a book coming out next month of
september on that when we do individual
therapy we still do this
but we use the representations inside
people's heads
so you have a cast of characters inside
your head so do i
i'm very thankful
my main attachment figure when i was a
child was my father
and i'm very aware that all through my
adult life especially through moments of
failure
moments of joy
key moments
i can hear my father's voice my father's
still
a reality for me right he's i carry him
inside of me and that's what we do with
our loved ones and we talk to them and
we have these dramas with them so if i'm
doing individual therapy
i might use these same reflections and
evocative questions
instead i'll say
you planned every interaction with your
mother you planned it for hours you
planned how to go and ask her for a hug
you planned right right
so can you see that little girl
who always got
smacked and taken back to her room and
left in the dark
can you see that little girl sitting on
the bed by herself
what would you want to say to her
what would you like to have been able to
say to your mum
and she says something like
i tried so hard mom i tried so hard but
i could never reach you
was it really my fault was i really such
a bad little girl
i just think you weren't a mum
you weren't a mum to me
say good
what does it feel to say that she says
that feels different
i've never said that before to myself
i've always said i didn't plan enough i
wasn't a good enough little girl
aha so can you say that again can you
see your mom what does your mom look
like in the chair close your eyes she
closes her eyes yes i see her say oh
what do you see on her face she says she
tells me she's tired she doesn't have
time
you know she's tired and she's working
three jobs and you know i should just be
quiet and go to bed and stop my
grizzling stop me that's what she's
telling me
and what do you want to say to her i
want to tell her mom that's not fair
that's not fair i'm just little
and i can never reach for you i can
never reach for you you're not a mum
you're not a good man to me i need a mom
and i say how do you feel about that she
says i feel fine
that feels good that feels different
then she emails me after the session
says you know sue the sessions with you
are hard so i don't understand why i
sing all the way home
and it's because she moves
in the session she moves out of her
obsessions addictions with not eating
addictions for planning
anxiety she moves and so she gets
exhilarated because she starts to feel
more whole as a human being
some of the cliches we have about love
are really awful
misinformation but one of the cliches
that's really true
and this is true in most religions
is that when we're loved we grow and
expand
we grow
we find more resources inside ourselves
we find more strength inside ourselves
we're better at problem solving
when we're safe and secure and we feel
we matter to others and that they have
our back
our potential and our resources come out
you